قال رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير الخارجات
القطري الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
ان هناك تقاربا في المواقف بين قطر وفرنسا
في عده مجالات وخلال مؤتمر صحفي جمعه مع
وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
قال رئيس مجلس الوزراء القطري ان دوله قطر
تعمل على توظيف هذا التقارب لتعزيز الامن
في المنطقه
هناك قضايا مختلفه سواء كان ما يخص لبنان
سوريا
ايضا ملف النووي الايراني هناك تشاور
مستمر بين الدولتين
ومحاوله من الدولتين
لايجاد حلول سلميه وايضا هناك تعاون على
المستوى المتعدد الاطراف سواء كان في
منصات الامم المتحده المختلفه التعاون كما
ذكرت هو تعاون متعدد الاوجه هو دائما ااا
يعني المواقف بين دوله قطر وفرنسا فيها
تقارب كبير ونحن نحاول دائما ونسعى البناء
على هذا التقارب
لتقديم شيء لتعزيز الامن في منطقتنا
هذا وقالت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
منذ فتره طويله وان البلدين بدا اليوم
مرحله جديده لتطوير هذه الشراكه
[موسيقى]
قطر الشريك استراتيجي لفرنسا منذ فتره
طويله واليوم هذه الدوره الثانيه من
الحوار الاستراتيجي نريدها ان تكون مرحله
جديده لتطوير علاقاتنا الثنائيه الدوره
الاولى عقدت في مارسا الماضي واردنا ان
نعجل في العمل وندخل في التفاصيل على اساس
اللقاءات والاعمال والاجتماعات التي عقدت
بين مسؤولين في البلدين هذا يدل على
الاراده المشتركه للارتقاء اكثر بهذه
العلاقه المتميزه والوثيقه اريد ان اشير
ايضا الى العلاقه المتميزه والوثيقه
القائمه بين الرئيس ماكرون وامير دوله قطر